Apple’s new iPad-specific OS, or iPadOS,
is coming this Fall and it’s bringing a
bunch of new features that make it more like
a computer than ever before, and this video
is a full guide on how to use the new split-view
and multi-tasking features, so let’s get
started.
Multitasking starts with the app dock, so
let’s fill it up with the apps we use every
day.
Something new this year is the ability to
put entire app folders onto the dock, so you
can have access to any app you want from just
the dock.
Starting with Slide Over mode, first open
an app, then swipe up from the bottom to bring
up the dock.
Then Drag an app onto the side of the screen,
but don’t drag it to the very edge.
You can now use both apps at the same time,
or drag items from one app into the other.
Like images, links, or files.
You can also swipe the bar on the bottom of
the Slide Over window to switch between other
apps you have open in Slide Over mode, Or
you can swipe up on that bar to show all of
the apps at once and choose which one you’d
like to use.
You can also drag the top of the Slide Over
window to the other side of the screen.
Slide over mode is very useful for doing things
like quickly bringing up the Files app and
dragging files into apps like Lumafusion for
video editing.
If you don’t have the desired app open in
one of your Slide Over windows, just drag
the app from the dock and it’ll replace
the current app.
Once you’re finished, just grab the edge
of the window and slide it off the screen,
and swipe again to bring it back.
To switch to Split-View mode, just pull the
top bar down and into the edge of the screen.
At that point, you can bring back the Slide
Over window by swiping from the edge, and
you can move it to the other side, just as
before.
And pulling down on the Slide Over apps top
bar will replace the underlying split-view
app.
Now in split-view mode, you can easily swap
the positions of the apps by dragging the
top bar of an app to the other side.
You can also drag the bar in center of the
apps to give more space to either app, either
in a 50/50 or 25/75 split.
To replace an app while in split-view, just
drag it from the app dock.
You can even use the same app on both sides
of the screen, which is useful for transferring
files in the Files app, and it should work
for third-party apps as well like Microsoft
Word, but it doesn’t seem to be working
yet in this first beta of iPadOS.
Within the notes app, you can even grab a
note and drag it to the side of the screen
to open both Notes side-by-side.
While the mail app is open, you can compose
a new email and drag the compose view to side
in either slide over or split-view mode.
Hit cancel or send and it’ll automatically
close.
The coolest part is that you can swipe along
the bottom of the screen to swipe between
apps, and all of the different split-view
app combinations you previously had open will
be saved, including as many versions of each
app as you’d like.
You can also swipe with 4 fingers instead
to switch between apps, or swipe up to get
to the home screen, or swipe up and stop at
the center to open the app switcher and choose
the app you want to use.
If you want to exit split-view mode, just
pull down on one of the apps tabs to get it
into slide over mode, then swipe it off the
screen.
Now let’s say you’re at the home screen
and want to start a fresh version of an app,
but it keeps opening up the same app that’s
already in split-view.
Well, simply tap and hold on an app in the
the dock or on the home screen, and tap Show
all windows to open the App exposé.
From here, you’ll see the various versions
of the app currently open, and you can swipe
to close them, or tap the plus icon to start
fresh.
If you want to get back to a different version
of the app you’re currently using, just
tap the same app within the app dock and it’ll
open up that same app exposé.
Now in Safari, we finally get automatic desktop
mode for browsing, and to split-view, just
tap and hold on a tab and drag it to the edge
of the screen.
You can also watch videos in picture in picture
mode if the video player supports it by tapping
the PIP button.
You can now swipe between apps and use your
iPad while the video plays.
You can tap to pause, close, or bring it back
to the safari window.
You can also drag it to any corner of the
screen, and spread with two fingers to make
the vidoe larger.
You can use PIP on YouTube, but it will only
play while that tab is open and you can’t
move it around, but it’s useful if you want
to browse YouTube.
Apple’s also added some text editing features
that can really speed up your workflow.
You can quickly pick up your cursor with one
finger and move it around anywhere you’d
like, or use two fingers anywhere on the screen.
You can also tap multiple times to select
different amounts of text.
Tap twice to select a word.
Tap 3 times, or for some reason 4 times in
this beta version, to select a sentence and
tap 4 times, or for us, 5 times to select
an entire paragraph.
You can then pinch with three fingers to copy,
and then spread with three fingers to paste.
To undo, you don’t have to shake it anymore,
just swipe left with three fingers, and then
swipe right with three fingers to redo.
And finally, you can pinch with two fingers
on the keyboard to shrink it, and then grab
the tab to move it wherever you’d like on
the screen, allowing you to type with just
one thumb, or use the new swipe keyboard feature..
Then you can pinch with two fingers again
to bring it back to the full keyboard.
So that was everything you need to know about
Multitasking in Apple’s new iPadOS.
If this video helped you out, tap like and
click the circle above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!